4000 فرنسي من مزدوجي الجنسيه يشاركون في
الحرب على قطاع غزه مع الجيش الاسرائيلي
بشان هذا الامر طالب النائب الفرنسي توماس
بورتس بفتح تحقيق مطالبا حكومه بلاده
بادانه الفرنسيين المشاركين في القتال
ومحاكمتهم في حال الاشتباه في ارتكابهم
جرائم حرب في
القطاع وينضم الينا الان من باريس توماس
بورتس النائب في البرلمان الفرنسي عن حزب
فرنسا الابيه صاحب هذا المقترح اهلا بك
معنا
لماذا صدر منكم هذا
الطلب قمت بهذا قدمت هذا الطلب لاننا
نلاحظ طبقا لما تذكره وسائل الاعلام
الفرنسيه بان 400 4000 115 جنديا يعملون
في الجيش الاسرائيلي في
غزه وبنظر الى الجرائم التي ترتكب هناك
طلبت من وزير العدل
ديموري وايضا النائب العام
الفرنسي هناك الفصل او الماده
40 تقوم ب تحقيق اذا كان هؤلاء الجنود
ارتكبوا جرائم حرب على الاراض الفلسطينيه
والاسرائيليه وفي حال ثبت ذلك ينبغي ان
يحاكموا على في فرنسا لانه لا يمكن ان
لمواطنين الفرنسيين ان يرتكبوا مثل هذه
الجرائم انت تتحدث عن مزدوجي الجنسيه ام
ان هناك وثبت لكم بان هناك من الفرنسيين
من يشارك في هذه الحرب رغم انه لا يحمل
الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه
في حسب المعلومات المتوفره لدي هناك
فرنسيون وهناك ايضا فرنسيون
اسرائيليون يحملون الجنسيه المزدوجه
وهؤلاء العسكريون
4185 ينبغي ان يتم التعرف عليهم وان يكون
هناك تحقيق لا يمكن ان نحكم على الناس
مسبقا ولكن نتاكد اولا حتى نجد ادله واذا
وجدنا انه لم يكن هناك ارتكاب لجرائم حرب
لا مشكله والا فان سيكون هناك محاكه ينبغي
ان يكون هناك محاكمه لهم وهل تجدون دعما
داخل البرلمان للبحث في موضوع جرائم الحرب
وبناء عليه الانتقال
الى وزير العدل والمدعي العام للحديث عن
هذه
القضايا
اليوم نحن في مرحله سياسيه في فرنسا
الحكومه الفرنسيه فيها وكثير من الوزراء
قدموا دعما كبيرا لاسرائيل والرئيس
ماكرون تطلب منه الامر شهر ونصف شهر لكي
يتحدث عن وقف لاطلاق النار
و وزيره الخارجيه ذهبت هناك
وادانت ما يقوم به المستوطنون
اذا ينبغي ان تصل هذه الطلبات او هذا
الطلب بالذات لوزير العدل
وقد كنت عرضه للعديد من الهجمات من قبل
اسرائيليين في البدايه كان هناك حديث عن
الدفاع عن النفس وتبرير لقصف المدارس
والمستشفيات وسيارات الاسعاف وتلقيت
الكثير من الشتائم
والتهم
وانا ارى انني هذا طلب مشروع بالنسبه لي
فرنسا دائما التزمت بالقانون الدولي وتسعى
لان يتم احترام القانون الدولي وينبغي ان
يفعل نفعل ذلك هناك مساله احترام وتقيد
بهذا القانون وينبغي ان نفعل كل ما نستطيع
لكي تتم محاكمه هؤلاء ان ثبت ضدهم جرائم
هل ترتفع اصوات اخرى بالاضافه الى صوتك
سيد بورت في البرلمان الفرنسي تطالب حقيقه
بالنظر بحياديه والنظر في ابعاد ما يتم
ارتكابه من جرائم حرب في داخل قطاع
غزه نعم هناك اصوات اخرى خاصه المجموعه
البرلمانيه
لفرنسا
الابيه وكذلك ك من المجتمع المدني من
يقومون بحملات عرفت ان ايريك كانتونا لاعب
كره القدم كان له
رساله حول اجراء تحقيق هذه مسائل حساسه
ودقيقه لان هناك في
فرنسا هناك صعوبه في
اثبات الجرائم التي ترتكب
وخاصه الاغلبيه الرئاسيه التي تقف الى
جانب اسرائيل ولكن هناك
كثيرون يرون بوضوح ان اسرائيل لا تدافع عن
نفسها ما تقوم به هو جرائم حرب نحن نواجه
جرائم حرب ونراها تدور امامنا وامم
المتحده تقول ذلك ايضا ومعركه
تبرنا على ان نفرض احترام القانون
الدولي اذا اذا جنبنا موضوع جرائم الحرب
باعتبار بانها مساله تحتاج الى فتح تحقيق
معمق مشاركه الفرنسي في حرب لبلد اخرى مثل
اسرائيل هل هو ضمن القانون الفرنسي مسموح
به
هناك امور مسموح بها بالقانون ولكن
القانون
يمنع على مواطنين فرنسيين ان يشاركوا في
عمليات عسكريه في اطار جرائم حرب او جرائم
ضد الانسانيه والمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه مهمه في تحديد ما اذا كان هناك
جرائم حرب لانه عبر هذا التعريف يمكن
القيام بتحقيق
واذا ثبتت ادانتهم ان تتم محاكمتهم وتصل
العقوبه اللازمه عليهم مره اخرى اعتقد ان
واجب فرنسا هو ان تعرف ماذا يفعل هؤلاء
الفرنسيون ال
4185 في صفوف حرب في جيش يرتكب جرائم حرب
بشكل يومي
رايت مجازر ترتكبها اسرائيل ضد المدنيين
الفلس
وينبغي ان يكون صوت فرنسا اكثر قوه في
الدعوه والحرس على وقف اطلاق النار نائب
في البرلمان الفرنسي عن حزب فرنسا الابيه
توماس بورتس كان معنا من باريس شكرا جزيلا
لك